Zach had a video I don't know if you've
seen it that went completely viral
roasting dislike attractive girl and it
was everybody just latched onto this
thing because it was like how it was our
revenge was every guy that ever wasn't
talked to by a pretty girl and some
funny tricks and Karen Feehan I think I
met her last night yeah who date's Lois
Jake oh man yeah my first battle and she
came in
she's great now she's done it a bunch
but she came in and I don't think she
really understood the concept hatred she
got the same mean things part but no one
gave her the part where it's also a joke
right and she just said like mean things
in a row and yeah it was funny she was
quick yeah she's very good there were
two video selections to choose from one
was 20,000 views one was two million
views Adrienne chose to me he's all good
yeah
I didn't it's funny I I I never knew her
before and watching her and Lewis roast
each other I thought she was really
funny and so is he I was like I give
them both credit like he didn't he took
the gloves off yeah that's a strong
relationship wasn't Bonnie or like that
they just say horrible she's like I
would be so resentful with my chick said
she like that to me you wouldn't be able
to handle it well no it's funny on stage
with the two of them when you're just in
a room with the two of them unbearable I
Love Lucy episode that never gets fun of
it so you're just roasting like how much
of your time is spent roasting versus
actually doing a traditional stand-up
after this tournament was literally just
a month of my life writing jokes cuz I
going more towards I'm doing a lot of
more roasts and then I do stand-up a
couple times a week but the roast thing
is starting to be taking my thing yeah
yeah yeah and when I was not gonna
mikelaurence about it he was just
talking about the research that a good
roaster has to put in right like cuz you
have to write jokes all the time you
also have to research to make sure
you're hitting the right stuff just all
the time yeah we can't reuse [ __ ] right
so I'm like spending all this time
writing and then I have to throw it out
like sometimes I can retool something to
make it about someone
yeah sure but you know with these we we
all kind of have an agreement that we
don't reuse anything on each other yeah
and you had a couple of specific I won't
repeat them today might air on Comedy
Central but there was a couple of really
[ __ ] means specific obviously from
research that I didn't know about the
other guy but it was still funny look
you don't have to know [ __ ] when
somebody references the death of someone
else's family member
ya know that it's serife expired or
whatever just know that you like in your
dead dad oh yeah the guy facing the
saving is that Evan Williams also really
funny yeah and we went out to a diner
together and just told each other every
said thing about our lives and I
realized half an hour into each other
telling you know each other who's uh
who's dead and whose family I was like
anyone walking by things were on the
world worst first date right now that
for this reason yeah we went out
together just to give each other [ __ ]
for rose battle Wow we all know that the
people that do it that the stand all the
time we pretty much if you're facing
somebody we make a point to go out
together don't have a meal and like to
become friends for that's like that Mike
Birbiglia improv movie except you're all
saying terrible things about each other
we just make [ __ ] up I'm devastated
because I was [ __ ] three models and
one of them died has anybody taking it
like to personally like to the point
where it's like ah that's like one kid
who I don't want to name was at the
stand and ran upstairs crying no little
rich boss he's just crying yeah what was
it was he bombing or was she bombing or
was it something somebody said about
them he was bombing and then I think
somebody just hit him with something he
wasn't ready for it was yeah as
somebody's bombing you don't let up at
all like you don't like you're still
going to kill you're not gonna go half
speed because they're bombing right and
then you make the bombing even worse
yeah me because they're at the point
we're like this is like a YouTube thing
like people like look up like there's a
whole roast culture now or people like
look us all up so you can't waste the
opportunity now two million views that's
it's almost three almost three million
cheese that's probably your big this is
so you really destroyed her in this one
I caught her I caught her off guard up
top in here a little oh yeah yeah comedy
career
poor kids box controller it won't be
able to last much longer with just the
double A's
jason'll areas he's actually the
funniest one on Louis's podcast which is
like saying he's the guy with the
highest t-cell count on the aides floor
I'm just kidding you look way better
before they go on stage that's great if
you want to see Google I don't know why
they call me nerdy comedian I think it's
because they wanted to make it started
as nerdy comedian the first day it
started getting shared and then it went
to chubby comedian I absolutely loved
getting called Michael Moore every
single day we're tweeting it out at a
gym and Sam show on Twitter so here's
what I like about her like did she got
her ass kicked in that one but she's
ballsy enough to still go out and do it
again like she said she was Carrie yeah
she was very funny in the roast pile and
so is Lois and she's hot yeah you go you
have to go and know guns blazing because
they Zack does all right you haven't
been here when Lloyd Kaufman has been up
here have you East ignores away Troma
yeah Zack does all that stuff but he
doesn't me does like naked rolls oh yeah
I did his last two features and in
exchange for that job he asked me to be
naked for a half an hour in his new
movie it was it was like a game of gay
chicken basically and
I refuse to back down Wow and so like
there's plenty of stuff out there about
you to make fun of yeah I'm a little
pretty open life but even Jeff Jeff Ross
the other day was like what are you
gonna say about Zack that's gonna like
shake him at this point right right it's
all there because like my whole act is
basically what's wrong with me you know
you're the some of your flaws something
big J told me once and I feel the same
way so I mean there's nothing you can
really say it's gonna hurt me at this
point right some of you I've done it
good naturedly there's only half a beard
what is the other one leave or something
you know
what do you mean half I get there
wandered like there's two beards yeah
zing-zing Jim Norton is gonna be a
rosebud good-natured weak awful Jill
came up to Josh good-naturedly you can't
see too good or what when they dry out
just keep it good-natured it's so bad
yeah it's so dad yeah well we were on
break I meant to tell you we were
talking about uh Trump and and Tom was
saying that it was the we was the one
thing that you couldn't get over was the
that he just completely denies climate
change it's so strange that you're gonna
have a president that's going this at
all and it's so funny that you brought
that up because I never forget like I
watched Celebrity Apprentice all the
time uh-huh and before he was running
for president or anything like that yeah
he stood in front cuz he just used that
show just to get cuz he loves being in
front of people sure and just saying
things yeah so he stands in front of
this group of celebrities and they're on
a roof in New York and it's like a cold
day you know it's the winter and he go
he's standing in front of them and he's
like so how many of you believe in
global warming and I'm like oh you must
be leading to what the big task is for
the episode yeah and like a couple of
them raised their hand and he just leans
in he goes so then why is it so cold
anyway
total nonsense yeah the other footage
was just a half an hour of him saying
the n-word do you know I heard they had
footage of that like him dropping that
but they guess they can't really see
because were afraid of being sued but I
heard that they had that a majors been
around her that rumors I feel like
somebody would have released it by now
if it exists maybe they would have taken
the big picture and just said this is a
political important the guy who created
it what's Mark whatever his name is
yeah Mark Burnett put out a thing as
soon as that rumor started it was like
nobody is allowed doesn't matter Edwards
no I'm [ __ ] and Bradley Manning
release [ __ ] I mean you know they don't
always care about getting in trouble for
something like that even though you'll
e-111 to gee I want to rush up bad
examples whatever
devil-may-care attitude I suppose yeah
why is it so cold because what if they
had tape of that and him saying that
would be a bigger picture than the
pettiness of suing someone for telling
for showing you that he's anyone who won
the popular vote too difficult for
Donald Trump to be able to come back
from that and by suing you know what I
mean like he would probably just want to
bury more Pinet with a suit as quickly
as possible and I don't think Mark
Burnett would have in the long run sued
because he would have come across like a
trump apologist maybe and if you drop it
and bombs although if you can get away
with saying that you grabbed a girl by
the [ __ ] you can get away with a lot
sure allegedly had that in the same
sentence describing the girl was a tiny
little laptop that's driving me crazy
this was the MacBook Air I hate the air
it's not good me I'm so good I mean it
is I mean light and airy it's no lie but
I mean [ __ ] small get all your work
done and like anything in [ __ ] Apple
why do they hate plugging [ __ ] in you
got a plug in anything what I don't know
my [ __ ] things that's true phone jack
in there it's the perfect by the way
he's got the new phone with no headphone
jack you got it you said the other night
we were gonna go together oh no did you
go with on top but my phone was [ __ ]
the bed I had to get a [ __ ] phone
where'd you get it I I went to
Verizon's I went to Apple on 68th they
had it black no [ __ ] uh sim I mean no
uh whatever [ __ ] unlocked the photos
Jimmy we were sitting at dinner the
other night
Jimmy's going through is his phone I
think it was Instagram or something your
phone is so much more interesting than
mine
everything every shot is just something
I haven't seen ever right like if
somebody's all like puppies and children
and if somebody took your phone would be
like yeah at least have the contacts
backed up that's fine if somebody took
Jim's phone to be oh [ __ ] by the way
people tell me we're talk about backing
up to the iCloud why I won't do it you
don't have to back your photos up but
you have to backup your text messages
yeah that's the problem the text
messages are the parameters
I don't care people see my dick right or
some girls twice I don't care about that
but can't you just backup photos I think
you could just you don't have to backup
text message you just click no there's
no item no there's no option for it I
don't know if that's true County leaders
have learned well I mean I take your
word for it
hmm you seem to have more protected do
you have anything on your phones act
that you wanted a committed relationship
for the last three years so they're all
really this phone is pretty okay yeah is
it clean this phone I could get stolen
it's just like playing the guitar and
[ __ ] for funsies yeah yeah so you don't
really you honestly like you don't care
you you lock your phone or no nope Wow
and you don't have pictures on there
you're embarrassed by no I mean I see
what you're saying I'm naked in like two
movies now so like it is what it is yeah
to be on Jimmy
I have a to gauge Prince Albert I want
everybody to see my car really yeah yeah
I stretch the ring for [ __ ] four
years I would engage I've got a 14 gauge
to be a regular yeah there's a 2g gauge
so that's like there's a big thick
earring in the head of his penis I was
like what's happening what are we
talking about which one is it to gazes
Smalling up there I'm with looking in a
picture of an ear yeah by the way the
small one
is a grotesquely large yeah wait you put
why would you put that in your penis
I've always wanted I saw them to be
strange land when I was in high school
and a guy gets his dick pierced and
everything I was like oh that's the
thing I need really
you're very sexually active in high
school I'm not till the end of high
school
Oh listeners I just showed Jim Norton my
[ __ ]
does it look painful yeah Wow Wow that's
always it's like it's like a hoop
earring at the end yeah it's a captive
bead so it you have to take use a tool
to take it out oh my geez when you have
sex you have to take it on oh god no you
know that's the only reason I ever used
to get laid why are you afraid of
getting ripped off for no no it's really
right in the meat I don't think you go
into the hole where you piss or no yeah
does that mean you piss on it when you
piss I guess but it is pretty sterile
yeah yeah but what about infection
though you worry about infection you
have to clean it to the smell cut I've
kissed girls on the neck uh and that
[ __ ] that little gay Jerry and they
have stinks yeah if you don't take care
of it but I mean I've never had a
problem with it I got it I was like 18
and I started stretching it after that
and I've never really I mean I'm also a
[ __ ] pervert so I used to have
dominatrixes hang [ __ ] off of it while
they beat me oh really because then it's
like a control thing where you can't
jerk off so I had a girl that used to
like put a like a gallon of water on it
and slowly fill it the [ __ ] release
you know but wait a minute so what how
the galley you dick you gonna rip off if
you don't do it properly you gotta do
that a certain she was a professional
yeah certain ones there's been I
register recently those like two three
girl who died because he was into
modification which is crazy to me I'm so
claustrophobic that does nothing for me
it's where they want to be mummified and
then a little halt cutting the thing
jumper you sunshine that's a saint it's
just right it's the same but I mean I've
met it I think it's not a lot of girls
likes luck it lists where they like
they're like I gotta try that once
I've like gotten what did they say is
that point to Mike a little more
what did they say about it does it is it
a difference when a girl really knows
her box
usually they know what position that
it'll work in and though they'll have a
good time Wow or they're just lying to
me but I don't care yeah you could sit
there and just say yeah I have a Prince
Albert to gage yeah and they're like
there's a there's women that'll be like
we I have to use that yeah I have that
should be inside gotta see than I would
ever have deserved in my life because of
that what a great trick I hope there are
a lot of people out there right now
they're not do not get lay they're just
all lining up to get their dicks pierce
you just try it yeah cuz you can just
take it out right yeah if you don't like
wait no but if you took it out now you
don't do that now I'd have like a hole
there
but it's not like pee would come out of
it like it would close up enough but it
would it's never gonna heal all the way
but you'd always have a hole in your
dick yeah that says Lord Lord it cuz
I've seen people who have the gage
what's it called the thing you have in
your oh there's a monrell and then this
in the middle is a lebrandt dilib right
I've seen people who had a little bread
taken out you can still see the little
hole right from it having been there I
never got pierced sir I don't like the
pain of it or no tattoos or any but just
kind of freaks me out it scares me yeah
but I understand the dominatrix angle I
knew a dominatrix who I used to see you
know the story Colin tells about we came
back from Iraq the eyes ran out of the
[ __ ] Airport to go see a dominatrix
yes but I didn't saying goodbye that's a
true story
that girl uh who was very very beautiful
she told me she would tell me stories
about clients not by name but just guys
that had done and she said one guy was a
doctor and he liked it when she would
take a scalpel and put it slightly in
the hole of his [ __ ] slice up not again
to do tremendous damage just to a tear
Tom that's kind of your thing right up a
little bit and the thing that he liked
about is when he would piss for the next
few days would burn and he would think
it would be like out of girls I'll spank
I'll spank you know I mean a mom about
hardcore but they like when they feel it
the next day
if you bite someone they like when they
feel it the next day it reminds them and
that was what he would like about it
apparently I was [ __ ] crazy so [ __ ]
can I still do the dominatrix thing no
my chicks uh I'm now in a committed
relationship with a preschool teacher
and she's uh yeah she ever bring home
perks yeah Prince Albert a kiss just
uncle Paul trying to set up really gross
threesomes about me you win a Care Bear
yay just a little shiny ring does your
gal ever want you just to take it out
and not have it around I'll tell you
she's gonna hate that I said this so I
its captive bead ringing you two'll take
it out for a while it was loose enough
that I could take it out because that's
a when I get blown like that's there's a
lot in the way right and it's like
knocking around in their teeth so like
they so for a while if she was gonna
blow me I would take it out but then it
got too loose
and one day we [ __ ] and afterwards I
took my dick out there's just nothing on
the end of it
I was like oh no and I reach in it no I
get the ring and I'm like oh thank god
and then I was like well there was a
ball at the end of this they're
squatting over the bed and me with like
two fingers like up against the wall and
I'm trying to because I was like I do
not want to go to the hospital at 3
o'clock in the morning for this it's a
real box of Cracker Jacks out a ring you
got it yeah I had to press it up against
like the wall of her [ __ ] and then like
slowly and yeah so he dropped something
between the seats yeah on the right when
you talk so when did you realize you
like dominatrixes what an adventure when
I realized that the only way this girl I
liked was gonna touch my dick as if I
let her beat me up and then it became a
thing until you really okay fine kick me
and then I just got into it shoes I
don't mind my dick slapped a little bit
like I can't ten not real pain but
there's something about I'll get a
massage one time and this girl like
she's so [ __ ] sexy
and she was like let me be naked and she
wouldn't touch my dick I'm so she's like
you dicks in the way and then she just
took it and she slapped it out of the
way not hard you like that but it was
like oh and she mentally just dismissed
it I was like [ __ ] yeah
years later I saw her in another state
and she wound up being very drunk I want
me to [ __ ] her in the ass but I wouldn't
don't cuz she was drunk so you had a
crush on a girl and she was like I like
to well if you let me beat the [ __ ] out
of you you can come over yes and that
that's the way she was into that or
she's yeah she was into that and she did
it I've never paid a dominatrix I've
always just kind of had these off and on
relationships with girls that were pros
and they kind of they liked hanging out
with me and that that's how it would end
up so did your girlfriend domina she
like Domino my girlfriend's ass up so we
are then tends to be my thing I likes it
you know not really cuz my two things
are either being very aggressive with
chubby girls my girlfriend's a chubby
muffin and or getting beat up by tiny
chicks it's like a Frankenstein syndrome
what a great way to put it yeah so it's
always been like little tiny girls to
beat me up
okay so [ __ ] like like Louis's
girlfriend she's smell like that that
build of girl exactly does your
girlfriend get insecure no she's pretty
cool with it yeah and yeah yeah she's
pretty open-minded she's a lot of fun
does she let you do that or no you don't
do it now you're oh no I don't care I've
been I've been a good this is the first
time I've ever been a good boy yeah if
you got somebody who can own you there
being owned by somebody it's not about
being thought it's a weird thing when
that one person like they make you feel
hi you're so turned on by them you like
[ __ ] stones like that when you'd find
someone like that you don't want to [ __ ]
it up because it's it's just rare would
you get turned on if somebody wrapped
you up in plastic wrap and then made you
wear a [ __ ] red lipstick you know
I've watched the videos with the guys
you're tied up I like it when they get
hand jobs that's pretty sweet
yeah but I do not trust a girl post me
coming with me wrapped up like that
because I'm too afraid she's gonna put
the comb on my face or something I'm too
afraid she won't where are you going
lady this job's not
I deserve a treat yeah Billings billion
yeah I don't think I would like my own
come on my I've told so many girls I'll
lick my coming out of your [ __ ] I'll do
that but man the immediacy of the mind
change when you come it did nothing
happens faster think I'll [ __ ] I'll
eat my own come no it's like when the
guy wakes up in 28 days later from the
coma just like oh this transactions over
that's exactly what it's like I know I
won't do it so yeah I'm not afraid I'm
afraid of just making a whole bunch of
promises that you're just not going to
keep yeah
that's it's dangerous in the moment
though you believe right like in the
moment you'll be like yeah nothing is
hotter in the moment than saying these
things but it's weird that you would do
you've had these relationships with
Dominique that's really lucky I've dated
girls who were really dominant and would
be perverts but I've never actually had
a relationship with a dominatrix yeah
just by being like that I didn't but and
I just get to hear all like the horror
stories of working at a dungeon by the
way 90% of which Hasidic Jews yes really
filthy there's a lot of the girl but a
lot of the doms would say yeah I would
make the guy hop in and shower
immediately there into scat there are a
lot of those guys are a really hardcore
then they have to bring the come back
home in the tissue because they can't
drop their seat on the floor oh that is
like the one Dom I dated said that I had
a guy that would come in and try to jerk
off while she was like turned around so
he could run out without paying I know
you're shocked right oh my god funny
I've heard the city guys can be pretty
[ __ ] hardcore because they're so like
their culture is not oppressed it's
repressed your press actually I I but if
there's a part of me that like they're
so lucky a lot of these guys because
they can not not necessarily Hasidic but
guys that can just come so easily for me
it's so many bells and with your the
hard for you to blow load like I get so
many bells and whistles I have to my
nipples got to be played with by I got
to be in a certain headspace like I
can't just sit there and get blown and
come now if I can have my nipples licked
and like two fingers
under my balls pushing up done you're
very I know me Tom yeah you don't need
any that stuff man you pretty normal
like with that yeah yeah this is all new
to me you can just believe you just like
when you [ __ ] do you need to have verbal
or - Sam doesn't talk what if I have to
have I don't talk much just like every
now and then maybe a little bit but not
much
I've said seven minutes is about as long
as I need and as long as I can get some
pumps in up I will be fine some pumps
yeah I'm just I'm still because you know
what I think about I think my mentality
still goes back to the kid in high
school didn't get laid and it's just oh
my god I can't believe this you happy
just happy to be there that's great man
I would give up all my perversions for
that yeah all of them yeah well you
don't waste any time with it look it's
like you think about it then you do it
and you're done and 15 minutes has
passed and you're ready to go about your
day you didn't mean you don't it doesn't
it doesn't take hours out of your life
well two perversions all come from
something that happened when you were
young or is it just instinct and try
things and you like him I can definitely
like my whole dominatrix thing yeah I
feel like I know the day that happened
when oh yeah because it's for me it's
like I like like a girl like yelling
like being super aggressive uh-huh and I
remember I shouldn't tell I remember
being a kid kid in the tub like young
and so young like when you get a hard-on
you don't know what it is you're just
like I don't know my body's doing right
and I mention being tough and not
jerking off not touching it just staring
at it being like what is this new thing
I do and at that moment my mom walks
into the bathroom and just goes and
slams the door and like a year into
dominatrix is yelling at me I remembered
that and I was like oh yeah that'll do
it wow that was the association with the
boner with you nights with a pretty girl
yelling at you like you know the
humiliation humiliation yeah I get crazy
though it just clicks in like I feel
like I saved a lot on therapy
remembering that yeah they're just gonna
say like it's probably really unusual
that you remember that like other people
have probably the end result but have no
idea where it came from
do you know where oh yeah I don't know
like I like it when an older woman sits
on my face and says eat Nana's [ __ ] why
granddad sleeps I don't know no I don't
know a lot from my Sunnah mice where
were you she was he's under the
misinformed belief that he was not
molested as a child I mean yeah that's
obviously been blocked out yeah yeah I
keep thinking I wasn't but then I just
keep walking up to this wall and there's
nothing behind it supposed to start
before you're 11 interesting that punk
in the [ __ ] tub yeah yeah here talk to
your mom I don't know I don't think I
mean hopefully nobody tells her you
started but you like paint oh so maybe
the pain in the dick is like my dick is
bad yeah I heard it I think it might be
yeah but it's weird what makes you what
sex is and what makes you [ __ ] it's
all so [ __ ] crazy like that for a
parent that one split second instinct
just decision like she probably didn't
think like later on and she probably
didn't know what to say right it was
such a weird moment she got emotional II
reacted she's twenty year old son in the
tub she has changed and warped her son's
sexual identity forever and it was like
yeah animate just to her it was like
doing the dishes just walking and clean
and getting stuff and oh my god that's
disgusting and Lee ain't no idea giving
it like got a strap-on or anything I
know I've had a like smart like eyed
girl put a blunt wrapper up my ass like
the plastic shell that a cigar would be
in there was a guy who told him like it
was a hard one okay okay did you like it
or no no I don't really I can't take it
that [ __ ]
yeah me too meant me too I'm almost
lucky like I've tried a little bit of
that but I just can't do it but it's not
a much of physical thing on a moral
thing my body's like
and I'm you're almost yeah otherwise
you'd have miles up there right yeah
disease factory you know it's dangerous
yeah I think so so so were you dating
like traditionally in high school it was
this one of the earlier girls that you
know I didn't get I mean I get late to
like the end of high school right I was
such a [ __ ] nerd off loser yeah and
then I just realized I can go [ __ ] fat
girls from other towns yeah and then uh
Arnoff relationships this chick that I'm
with now I think it's the first girl
I've ever dated long-term that wasn't
some type of sex worker how long I'm
with her for three years now
Wow I tend to like sex workers too it's
almost like with the sex worker you
don't have to explain okay look this is
my bag this is who I yeah they're okay
with it and then you know you have
there's other worse than liking somebody
you know you're not gonna have to deal
with their father ever exactly alright
once a year on that day you're gonna
have to hold her and go it's alright it
was his fault but aside from that you're
not gonna have to put up with him yeah
but it's weird that you have to explain
you weird section they get it and you're
not gonna fall in love and go oh gosh
she can't turn me on
that's the worst when you like a girl
but they just don't get that part of you
and it's like I'm gonna just cheat yeah
cuz you can't you're not satisfied with
just some pumps no like if that's all
you need I never have I've never thought
like Oh what if she can't turn me on
because it's well she's a female it
should be fine yeah I mean she should
already yeah jealous of a sex worker
goes out and does another work that
would make me jealous like again I don't
object to it but if I was if I was
dating someone they were actually
actively dominating or actively I would
be kind of jealous yeah I can't be
faithful to the times I've dated sex
workers I just had too much of a hang-up
and even if I tried I would just present
them in my own weird way and like I had
a cheat could you'd be like I want to do
this and like well I can't I got a
session or whatever yeah one was a cam
girl so I was like I wouldn't even like
in my own bedroom she'd be like all
right a private show so I'd have like go
[ __ ] off for an hour and I was just like
so much resentment in me I wasn't mature
enough at the time to figure it out I
don't know cam girls wouldn't I don't
know how mind as much just because it's
they're not being physical and they make
sent money they don't get to keep enough
of that money I get it when you're young
no because it's like you have to leave
now cuz I have to talk to this guy on
the computer sure like we're gonna be
you know as close as he's gonna think
that we're in love or what and that
[ __ ] with you yeah she had one guy that
literally was Santa Claus he was an old
fat guy with the big white beard and he
would jerk off and say hohoho send her
presence you know you've been a very
good girl and send her presents it was
the creepiest [ __ ] yeah that's a little
creepy did she do it throughout
hopefully an anonymous and a web site
bad guy she was on but this [ __ ]
dum-dum put her Amazon wish list up with
her real name and address that's a
rookie mistake the creepiest part of
that story is though you know that guy's
at mall Santa oh absolutely you know
he's sitting there one of those guys
that you've put your kid on his lap when
he wears the suit home and jerks off in
it and sends like [ __ ] cam girls
gifts and looks yeah you want to call
the show it's eight six six nine six
nine one nine six nine zac amico is here
with Tom papa Joe in New Jersey welcome
to Jim Norton and Sam Roberts Jacob's
Ladder and uh five piercings down the
bottom I shot what I've heard of that
I've seen photos of that gender like
surface piercings along the skin yeah it
started off as one you know he's never
had a girlfriend that had a Jacob's
Ladder what's that the Jacob's Ladder I
wouldn't go for it all the piercings
they love it once they find out it's it
it's incredible they're showing a touch
it don't look to anything see I don't
like you I don't like like [ __ ] rings or
[ __ ] hood rings I like a [ __ ] I like
genitals just to be gentle like I like a
[ __ ] to have like a smell to it and
have [ __ ] a big nice fat clip I don't
like a ring to it but I guess I could
see what women would find that cool
because diction I guess boring to most
women because every guy wants to show
his stupid dick right well I got yeah I
put a hat on it fix it do something oh
so you do that they're like that's
different it is so interesting though
that so much of penis piercing culture
is about just what they're gonna want to
touch it or see it if I do this - what
right it's not good enough just if I
could dress it up a little yeah yeah
yeah I'll accessorize it and then
they're gonna want to touch it and once
they touched it I could get it in their
mouth yeah all the accessories Julie
that's a good point yeah I guess so was
that you was that was that your issue
Zach you needed to add some decoration
to it well it was just a great like I
remember because I've had my dick
pierced twice I got it once in high
school I actually had the top rung of
the Jacob's Ladder so I'd like a little
ring through the surface I got it on st.
Mark's from this big African guy I just
remember he went you have to pull it out
more and I'm like it does not come out
which by the way the last guy you want
telling you pull it out was the big
African guy who Pierce's dicks
yeah but yeah I remember I had in high
school I remember just girls that never
spoke to me before like hot little
Spanish girls were walking up to me in
the hallway grabbing my dick because
they heard really to touch it it was
like that level of like because they
found out Adebisi at Pearce today yeah
I'll just lie really but what's in their
mouth were they gonna do it must have
fallen out yeah I lost it check it's
under it's under I mean half the band I
got my monitor I have a little stud
right here cuz when girls go oh did that
hurt I'm not as bad as the one of my
dick it's a conversation starter it's
like a very subtle arrow that's smart
move that's [ __ ] incredible though
for a nerd to be able to figure out a
way that you can have chicks grabbing
your dick in high school or just the sad
story of a boy who was willing to let a
man stabbed him in the [ __ ] I think I
think there are a lot of high school
dudes
that if they found out that really did
happen they would do it they would do it
I think like I remember like three or
four other guys in my high school class
getting dick rings after me because they
heard and saw girls touching my dick in
the hallway that's the idea
a movie called strange land that Addie
Snyder made uh-huh and it's uh it's 90s
[ __ ] it's like about a guy who meets
girls in chat rooms and kills them and
he's like all covered in piercings and
tattoos and one guy he ties up and
Pierce's his dick and this day I saw
that movie I just remember oh you do
people do that I want that oh and then
you got ed and then your dream came true
yeah that's amazed that designer in the
movie yeah that's pretty cool it's a
cool movie he did he directed it
yeah he wrote and directed it I believe
and it was good yeah I like I mean it's
very like silly 90s now cuz it's like
all in like AOL chat rooms right you're
also like a like a b-movie guy yeah Bob
sigh I like I love bad horror movies
yeah it this is just like it's such a
perfect portrait of that exact time in
the 90s there was he blood sucking
freaks that's trum movie yes he's that
Romani little Ronnie there was a ralphus
a Ralph fish sir right Ronnie was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] unnies thing Ralph fish
that's right
yes that's a great movie yeah blood ii
freaks is one of the early trophies it's
the first it's the first movie Troma
ever released it was called Sardu it was
under another name and then they gave it
blood sucking freaks is like an
exploitation all name okay but that's a
[ __ ] great movie by the way Zack was
also in return to Newcombe high volume
one and we'll be in volume two as well
that's a Troma's Kill Bill turn the
Neukom high volume one and Sam was very
nice to come to our premiere at the
Alamo for volume one yeah nice
Troma nerd forever oh yeah house right
at the Alamo they just don't want in
Brooklyn but Sam came to the one in
Yonkers yeah there's a really good one
in Yonkers
I've never been to one of those I heard
they're good really cool that's good
there's a one in Brooklyn called the
Nighthawk and just it's such a nice way
to see a movie yeah you could eat dinner
oh yeah full dinner and it's just like
it's a little bit more money but it also
is just a nice way to see a movie and
you
also know that people who are gonna be
rude during a movie wouldn't pay that
much extra right but how do they resolve
all the noise from the dinner it's not
noisy you have a card where you you
order on paper so like you write down
your order you put it in front of your
seat and a waitress or waiter comes very
quietly takes it brings you your order
there's no talking yeah it tends to be a
little like I don't wanna say upper
class but it's a little like bushi
yeah well hipstery so people are like
very at and then a lot of those theatres
I think the Alamo has a no talking
whatsoever policy yeah like they put up
a thing where like you can I'm the on
the things that you write on to order
your food right if you just write the
person next to me is texting then
they'll look at it they'll go okay and
then they'll go back around and if they
get two cards you're thrown out if you
and they won't let you come in late they
won't need no talking no texting you're
coming in late know any of this there's
all white people and it's reserved
seating too so you know what you're
gonna sit you do it on there any light
though to see there's your little lights
of the seat there these little tiny like
there's very pendulums yeah okay under
the movie no no not at all I want to do
that I've heard a lot of great things
come over I'll take you out to dinner in
a movie which is better is that is the
one in Brooklyn better or the one you
want to Brooklyn just opened I want to
say like yeah well meantime really
really recently I like the one in
Yonkers better because I like everything
in Westchester better so I will go for
the one in Yonkers you live there I do
yeah the one in Yonkers is like ten
minutes from my house I've never been to
one I'm gonna go oh yeah most broad
there Oh classy date hey food is good
food is good yeah do you order during
the movie or before it you could do
either one oh I like to eat from the
beginning of a movie I mean that's just
me unlimited popcorn tell me more about
this Jim a movie without popcorn
well they sell like chicken and yeah
it's a like restaurant yeah whatever you
not like movie theater food it's like a
restaurant in the back
they got vegetarian stuff everything
although the vegetarian stuff might be
too fattening I'm gonna go the ominous
dog gonna have to treat myself after I'm
December 17 think me a little treatment
sounds nice is that because that's the
special operation skirble here in city I
want to shoot I want I take the first
thing I want to eat after I shoot is I
want to go to and get Joe's pizza
yeah or John's Joey are you huh no I
think you're a [ __ ] fighter and you
need to have a cheat day after your big
fight like oh no I'm training right now
I in society so I'm fighting the urge to
throw something at you no I got I just
know I'm a [ __ ] compulsive creep and
it's like I want to just do it and then
ya know I need some pizza I'm gonna feel
a little freer at the finish line
yeah yeah I love pizza they got lo they
got pizzas at the Alamo
do they oh yeah my shitty though yeah I
don't know I don't get him I don't get
him but I come by will double in Yonkers
in Yonkers hopefully yeah yeah I don't
think Jim's gonna go and I think you
know my way there yeah Skirball is a
nice spot Jimmy yes yeah I shot there
once in 2006 excited about it
very yeah yeah very excited are you al
are you haven't IV you shot for for the
Comedy Central thing that they were
shooting for the roast thing that Jim
yes but I don't know if I'm gonna make
it they did seven battles and there's no
guarantee they're gonna have to edit it
down to an episode if you what but you
won like the thing I learned the
tournament the stand and from that they
hired me for that for the taping for you
no idea if I'll make it all that is
enough to get your foot in the door yeah
that sucks
that was my first that's gonna be my
first real credit I think yeah
congratulations thank you Tom you think
he'll get in Jim I have no idea how it
works behind these leaves he was funny
enough to get in but I never know how
networks work things behind the scenes
they had us close which is cool yep
so even if I don't make it it was cool
to you know close out a huge show like
that yeah
you make it if you've been awarded a
championship belt for comedy I feel like
you should buy ice my girlfriend came
home the next day and I was asleep with
the belt funny fast-forward a few years
you're gonna be breaking it up and
taking a digital jewels from the belt
mister amico the belt of a champion is
very rare have you done the naked Shawn
Michaels pose with it yet where it's
just wrapped around your leg and you've
got nothing else on do you think I did
anything else put that [ __ ] belt off
naked Shawn Michaels posed for Playgirl
when he was WWF champion in the 90s and
it's the most homoerotic wrestler shot
look at this that zac amico with his uh
with his roast masters roast battle
championship second-best Playgirl spread
behind Peter Steele from Type O Negative
what did Peter steal his [ __ ] is [ __ ]
tremendous yeah holy your breasts
looking with the roses over it is
ridiculous flowers and candles on it
yeah I know there's a shot of his
[ __ ] what Adrian is your safe search
on or something yeah what are you doing
it like you don't [ __ ] know where
this is yeah just look it up on your
phone if you have to it's right look up
Peter Steele Playgirl new did new [ __ ]
trust yeah I've seen this man's [ __ ]
there it is they show hard-ons and uh I
don't like showing off his giant boner
and Tim's going I don't like his face
yeah I mean what are you gonna show him
flaccid absolutely I think that Toro
became hardcore like there's Playgirl
rules the girls hot but you know you
don't mind his dick you just don't like
his face
oh yeah predict either way I didn't know
he has a terrifying caveman person he's
[ __ ]
weird-looking yeah I guess so
he's got a good body though which he's
alive now Peter Steele did die okay
that's the guy that what he died of
drugs heart attack his dick was too big
all the blood rest away from the band
you're in good shape with a big penis
hot girls will [ __ ] die early you
look down and got scared today I don't
know
died of heart fail a war - can you ISM
well Jesus Christ
Oh 2010 okay you know I think they did a
great cover of paranoid it was real slow
finished
wasn't so good yeah it was really weird
aneurysm scare me because it apparently
did just happen the head like that
basically waiting for something you
think I'm a high aneurysm risk got a big
antic they'd never be able to find the
problem we don't know we don't know
aneurysm scare me just one day hey the
show got a lot funnier we should take a
break
yes Zack is here he's hanging out
Zack is not funny on Twitter at za c
there's no K and you got any and now of
course the real last podcast with you
and Louis and are you doing any gigs
coming up uh yeah come see me at the
stand on the 28th free show frantic me
Ehrenburg bunch of really funny people
and just realized podcast that's a
that's my thing okay cool and Tom well
I've got a show tonight a big show
tonight at the Village Underground that
come to pop a live radio show with Gary
Gulman and Ryan Hamilton et cetera
that's tonight at 8:00 and my uh my new
special comes out on epics on December
9th called human mule maybe you'll see
the billboard in Times Square just to
remind you of what's it's not a big deal
it's just you know me in a big picture
it's not a big thing did you have
anybody awesome direct it's cool they
called it human human mule to : honestly
oh yeah more accurately we've been sucks
a big
so who direct it was Rob Zombie do it no
the amazing J Chapman J chap yeah you
got it in Cleveland
it's Valerius and they'll be on December
no I can't wait to see joy and you'll
come back to talkabout sure we'll do a
junket he shot an opening uh just scenes
of Cleveland let's kind of drift how
long's Eddie
how long is what opening the opening is
a minute do you have a dope opening for
this special I don't know I mean you
don't know working honest you're not
confident
I didn't we had some really good
openings yeah I got Jim had Omar from
the wire assault him in one of the
openings you've you're a king of the
opener well no I just I just do things
that mean something clever to me you
know they don't mean half the population
who didn't at that time know who Michael
K Williams was the audience got it
because they knew I liked him my head
what if I do that like no